okay let's move on to
the monk donde pawnee so
i think it was 20 13 or 14.
so in toronto i was a member of
entrepreneurs organizations a big
chapter there's 140 members they're all
entrepreneurs
every month they'd always have some kind
of event in downtown toronto
let me just i'm not sure why youtube's
not showing your comments sorry about
that joseph i just
proved it i don't know why they did that
and every month they would have a um
a dinner event and there was a keynote
speaker
uh usually it would start with a kino
talk then they would bring
you know the food out and this one was
different i've never seen
anything like this one before because it
went into woo-woo territory like i've
never seen
but just just stick with me on this so
we all get there
you know shake hands you know running
some guys you haven't seen in a while
have a
a drink and out comes this uh monk
looking guy with
beads you know monk garbs he's got these
three lines on his forehead so basically
it looks like he took
uh you know his three fingers and put it
like white paint and just went across
his forehead like this
um darker skin guy i think he was
indian if i'm not mistaken uh but he
spent 10 years in a monastery in hawaii
interesting dude very very interesting
dude and
when he left the monastery and wanted to
go and do the next thing and work on the
next chapter's life he decided well
i learned a lot about controlling the
mind controlling energy
and what energy vampires are and how to
dispense energy when
it's it's useful when it's not and one
thing that stood out he said where
where your awareness goes your energy
will flow so let's go back to the guy
with the bmw he cuts you off
driving along all of a sudden this guy
cuts you off and all you can think about
is that one car on the road
there's hundreds of other cars but all
you can think about is that one a hole
with the bmw that cut you off and all of
your awareness goes to that one thing
and that's where all of your energy now
flows
it's it's basically robbing you of your
energy unnecessarily because you're
allowing it to happen
and one of the simple notions that he
taught us that day
in his talk and you know this is a guy
that just kind of sat there
you know very very calm with his arms
crossed his legs crossed over i can't i
can't sit like that i have no
flexibility but
these guys spend you know 10 years
meditating and not not talking that much
so they're
so they're good at this stuff anyway so
he's explaining to us
that it's like a ball of light energy
and your awareness is like a ball of
light in your mind and it lights up
different parts
right like as it moves around it's
lighting up love hate
resentment guilt joy
sadness all these parts of your mind and
if you can figure out
how to manage that ball of light and
what it's going to light up and what
you'll allow it to light up
you can you can have control of your
mind which in turn allows you to have
more control over your life
because for the most part we just kind
of sleepwalk through our lives with
where we
let our minds light up and where we give
away energy or
if somebody wants to steal it from us
and waste our time
one of the techniques that i got really
good at when i was
running my business on a day-to-day
basis is
i just got hammered throughout the day
by
my staff i had like close to i think 25
or 26 staff at one time
i got hammered throughout the day
everybody's like stopping by my office
asking me a question hey what do you
think about that how do i solve this
and i got so tired of thinking for
everybody i
talked to my mentor at the time and he
goes look do this
the next time somebody comes to you with
a problem tell them
to come back with two solutions to the
problem
he goes what you'll what you'll see
happening very quickly is they won't
come to you
with problems anymore because what
you're doing is you're forcing them to
go use their own damn brains
and solve the problem and he was right
and that saved me a lot of my energy and
a lot of the f's that i needed to give
away for stupid things like helping them
like
if i'm hiring you as an employee do your
job and solve problems like you're
like you're a human resource i'm i'm i'm
paying you to do a job
go ahead and do it you know use your
brain like i'd rather you i'd rather you
go
and get it done and not have it done
perfectly and if we need to adjust the
behavior next time you know we can do
that
but i want people thinking for
themselves and that worked really really
well
so probably within about two to three
weeks
a lot i had a lot fewer visits to my
office distracting me from what i was
doing trying to rob me
of my energy and my focus and my f's to
give to them to solve their daily
problems instead if they showed up
and they didn't have two solutions for
that potential problem
i would send them away and they would
come back or sometimes they wouldn't
even come back and they would just solve
the problem on their own
so as a guy gentlemen and the handful of
ladies that watch this channel that are
looking to level up
you have to get familiar with a simple
notion
of how to manage your energy
you